INJURED GUYS  IN COVID
SITUATIONS.
HE IS MISSING HIS  VASILEVSKIY
THE STOP.
>> Brian: THAT WAS
>> Brian: GOLDEN SIX STRAIGHT
S BEEN A SOLID DEFENSE FOR
THEM.
HE HAS REACHED 500 GAMES ANANIN
ON THE BACKBOARD TAKES A HIT ON
PUTS IT ACROSS .1-TIMER SAVED
BY BY
SEVERSON.
SEVERSON PASS MISSED  THE POST.
FREE.
ANDREAS JOHNSSON IS THERE.
SO IS TY SMITH.
ANOTHER GIVEAWAY SHOT BY
Brian
HE IS DOWN EARLY.
BECAUSE HE IS A BIG GUY, HE
KEEPLIGHTNING GILLIES.
ONDREJ PALAT TO THE LINE FOR
HEDMAN.
AND THEY GET THINGS SET UP.
HERE RIGHT SIDE.
MATHIEU JOSEPH STICK CHECK. TO
HIS MAN.
AND TY SMITH DEFENDED HIM SAVE
CIRELLI IN SHORTHANDED!
OUT WIDE.
PENALTY SHOT IS
>> Referee: FOULED FROM BEHIND.
>> Brian: AND HE O HAS
BEEN GOOD.
AND HERE WE GO.
CIRELLI TAKES IT WIDE
BACK BY GET.
HISCHIER TURNS.
LOOKS AROUND AND BEATS THE PALA
POINTS HE IS ABLE TO PUT UP CON
THIS REBOUND.
HE MAKES A SAVIOR.
THIS ONE WAS A LITTLE IT IS BAS
BASTIAN INTO THE CORNER FOR
PRATT.
BACK UP AT WAS CRITICAL WITH SO
RIGHT JERSEY SINGING AROUND.
>> Dave: THEY GOT THE